Jeff Passan is a buzzkill he works for
Yahoo Sports covering baseball and he
dropped the bombshell that Shohei Otani
has got some issues with his elbow I
don't know if there's a precursor for
Tommy John surgery but all of a sudden
sent all the writers scrambling there on
wait what did the Angels get Jeff joins
us now can you give us the full
diagnosis here on what exactly happened
what's this mean Jeff well I'm not a
doctor I'll preface everything by saying
that but he has a first-degree strain of
his own a collateral ligament now if you
were to go and take an MRI of a 360 or
so pitchers in baseball right now
hundreds of them would have similar
issues in their elbow it's just the
attacks of pitching but the problem here
is that it wasn't just the elbow stream
man it's the fact that he needed a
platelet rich plasma shot and when you
get a PRP shot that is essentially
saying something is up in your ah there
are a couple of guys out there who do it
preventative Lee but the fact is okay
itani through only five games this year
because he had a hamstring injury that
kept him out most of the time when he
did come back there was a lack of
control he wasn't throwing his splitter
nearly as often as he had in the past
and both of those things screamed that
there is an issue and the fact that he
rose regularly 98 200 velocity
correlates very strongly with elbow
issues and I'd like to say I hate to be
a buzzkill on this but it's something
that really needs to be to be looked at
and that the angels need to manage now
he's back throwing at this point there's
no thought that they're gonna have to
keep him out but they're gonna happen
manage his workload for certain and the
answers are going to a six-man rotation
they've already gotten in touch with
some of their other pitchers saying as
much and this is going to become a new
reality in baseball I think we're gonna
see the six-man rotation more and more
this time goes on and I think it may
just become a regular thing
what did teams know before they were
able to flirt with Otani when were they
given a
a physical or did they have information
on his health yeah there was a physical
done November 28th and that's his goals
done in Japan by the Hokkaido Nippon Ham
Fighters doctor and it showed that there
was what they said was tone in the UCL
which is that it was slightly stretched
out now that's not a huge problem in and
of itself but the fact that there's as
much marginal value with this guy
anybody I have ever seen on the free
agent market I mean the sign with the
Angels for 2.3 million dollars plus a 20
million dollar posting fee and if you
can get somebody under six years of
control 23 million dollars who
potentially could be a number one
starter and who they who may believe is
going to be a number one starter even if
he does have elbow issues that's still a
deal you're gonna make a hundred ten
times out of hundred I don't think the
scared teams off by any means but it's
definitely something that they were
talking about and while they knew that
it was there and while they were
concerned about it they felt like the
upside there is so enormous and when I
said marginal value I mean the the
amount of money that he's worth compared
to what he's being paid it's to
essentially hundreds of millions of
dollars and they said you know what even
if he needs Tommy John surgery he'll mr.
season and he'll come back it doesn't
still be worth a whole lot more than the
other options out there but I didn't
understand this Jeff that he comes over
two years prior to where he could have
made a couple of hundred million I'm
gonna guess on the open market if now
correct me if I'm wrong but at age 25 he
comes over and then he's free to
negotiate and get a salary of whatever
he wants which the open market is gonna
bring him a couple hundred million I'm
gonna guess is that correct and why
would you come over now instead of wait
two years we still don't know the answer
to that question and the best guess from
people who have gotten to know him is
that he just really wants a challenge of
playing in Major League Baseball and
that money is not the thing that drives
him in it I know that's a wee
thing to think that because we're so
steeped in this sporting culture where
guys are squeezing every last penny that
they can out of genes that we've become
used to it the notion of somebody
playing to the challenge in the
competition and the love of the game and
the desire to be at the highest level it
just doesn't resonate it seems odd but
that I think was the motivation in
calculation for Otani and I put his his
lack of money so to speak where his
mouth is by going ahead and doing it I
do wonder though with this diagnosis
that he's had with the elbow payment he
had whether he made a calculation that
going over to a major league training
staff to a place that has better is
better equipped to deal with arm issues
was part of the calculation dumb just
how much blame does derek jeter deserve
with what's going on missed in a lot of
it because Derek Jeter I wrote this he's
he's acting like an amateur in a game
where you have to be professional and
part of this is the fact that Derek
Jeter has never done this before and
that being CEO is a lot different than
being a shortstop Derek Jeter toward the
end of his career believed that he could
play shortstop well when it was pretty
evident he couldn't and he believed that
he deserves to be the number two hitter
in the Yankees lineup when he did and
it's that confidence that drove him to
be as great as he was but it also
hampered him and right now he's acting
like the guy who's hitting 230 and said
I want to be in the middle of the lineup
anyway and I hope that for his sake to
the Marlin sakes Major League Baseball
say that he can understand and
comprehend hey I've made some mistakes
here I should have talked with John
Carlos and I should have given him the
lay of the land what we want to do where
we want to be what the direction of this
franchise is and and gotten off to a
better start with him so we could have
facilitated the right kind of trade for
both sides and in the end I think he
tried to play
a little bit like a mob boss where he
says it's going to be this way because I
say it's going to be this way and it was
a complete miscalculation
because Giancarlo Stanton in the end had
all the power that no trade clause he
wielded it the right way and he ended up
in a place he wanted to while the
marlins ended up getting pennies on the
dollar for the National League MVP does
Jeter get a ring if the Yankees win this
year thank you Jeff
we appreciate your time Jeff Passan
Yahoo Sports Baseball columnist for more
Dan Patrick show to the audience Channel
239 on DirecTV or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]